fire
[Music]
every had Vietnamese noodles ah yeah I
am bin Mason I've had quite a few I've
definitely never had fun and when I tell
people that especially in LA they gasp
let's try some nudes like a helmet so
this [ __ ] yeah it's fun this is the most
delightful hot tub like I could just
swim in this and drink it oh my gosh do
you [ __ ] with it I do [ __ ] with it I'm
living right now beef tripe
ooh that's intestinal lining hmm it's
like eating tender strands of a wallet
it's a very clean broth it's just a good
way to like fix you up after you've had
too much to drink if you get too [ __ ]
up pho yourself up in the morning this
looks [ __ ] delicious comes with an
egg roll I'll take six we were missing
one key ingredient this house oh dang
kind of smells like a vet so that's the
thing about a lot of enemies dishes we
just love to stuff our dishes with
veggies and kind of bounces everything
out it's a little symphony or not you
know my take my finger went in the
Czar's
oh my god hmm that pork is good you try
yeah yeah it's tender it's flavorful
I feel like the fish sauce is really
imperative just kind of like weaves
everything together in a really good way
mode job fun job you say boom away the
movie
it's so festive it's a lot of depth and
spice in it it's really good [ __ ] is
that that's not a lot you don't need a
lot alright so we mix it in I think the
shrimp paste actually changed the game
it is more complicated but I don't know
if I like it more because my mouth is on
fire the soup is a little spicy you're
trying to stay calm it's very spicy for
me so so you may be laughing it like
shut up to the back of my nose no
they're all my favorite but five always
have a special place in my heart I'm
very happy I finally got to try for I
will be ordering that the next time I go
way too hard at the club we're not gonna
start a GoFundMe but someone else can
it's called the bring Zach and Keith to
Vietnam Fund we will come we will eat
all your noodles thanks we'll see you
there in the description of the event is
[ __ ] no Eugene but you nailed it
[Music]